les réunions chez samsung je trouve que
ma tablette tu vas pas vu non oh oh tu
désolé retable est ce que j'ai cassé un
téléphone pliable
j'adore les débats mais oui c'était
l'année des jets le bitcoin égard mais
un euro [ __ ] j'ai gagné dix bals
s'emballe on est millionnaire et
milliardaire sommes tous perdus chez
youtube on vient on a vendu combien de
bonnes - youtube premium 2 d'abonnement
et ukrainiens devraient de deux
abonnements up
enfin des abonnés 1 ah oui un shooting
dogs pour écoute tu sais chanter non on
était majeure meta au mois un talent non
alors bienvenue chez tik tok si les
sites d'actu alors les news du jour
aussi cookies bon je sais babassu pour
aller accepte les coûts mais chez moi
pas après je ne dormais plus accès
ce n'est pas d'actualité chez disney bon
les gars s'ils tendent idée de film qui
peut apporter un maximum de penfeld je
vous écoute en propose de faire le
royaume mais ça existe déjà le remake en
images numériques et des nouveaux
acteurs qu'ils aient le vigneron le
remake pas besoin de scénario on va pas
se fouler
qu'est ce qu'on attend pour faire des
remakes chez le bitcoin quoi ça était
rome moi non mais dibble milliardaire
hall a tout perdu
chez tesla nos voitures autonomes ça
cartonne un jour on aura peut-être des
employés autonome pause-café grave grave
chez marvel attendait dans nos films le
héros est toujours accompagnée d'un mec
un peu nul et ben on va faire des films
sur ces mecs un peu nul oo et quand ils
sont connus on fera la vente jersey mec
un peu nul qui sont devenus cool aux
lakers chez disney la belle et la bête
le remake
le roi lion le remake remake chez les
malades ont formé de partout dans les
grandes villes
oh oui et on assiste à la télé ouvriers
qui sont d'application d'hier on peut
même monter à 3 dessus c'est une idée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chez gandi crush on bat les gars on a
bien bossé chez time idées de merde
l'idée merde on peut monter à 3 dessus à
l'évasion montana grave ça c'est paraît
il gtv et ça sera un petit onglet on
pourrait y mettre des vidéos
allez story te dire non ça sera un
onglet à côté on pourra m'aider bino
plus longue
non mais les vidéos elles sont déjà dans
le film et à se fait pas dans le film
justement sur un côté mais c'est nul ça
gtv personne n'a utilisé ne fait pas le
faire chez yucca incroyable cette
application concerne les produits trop
sucrés et oui c'est ça
trop salée à bourg forcément ça c'est
plein de trucs moches et moi trop gros
bond chez google et basse tu veux en
fait c'est un service pour jouer en
ligne t'as pas besoin de conçoit le coin
ce taser et ben en fait une connexion
internet ça suffit n'importe quel écran
s'en fout tu peux jouer quoi et bah t'as
pas besoin de consort le problème c'est
que j'ai pas trouvé de nom - eh ben
c'est à dire c'est super comme moi
j'adore franchement con c'est à dire se
prend pas la tête quoi chez playstation
spyro le dragon médiévaux le peuple
s'est crashé resident evil le remake
chez combine on a bien bossé
oui c'est la pause déj ouais on mange
quoi abba libanais tient même année ça
fait longtemps
perso samouraï sam savoure t ball à pied
[Musique]
squeeze quoi j'ai des libéraux ah bah
c'est pas trop tôt bonsoir fait beaucoup
mal ça cassation a cassé en deux
courants merci il attendait foutez de ma
gueule à lula sont sucrés à lula sont
sucrés blessure si vous y retournez voir
annuler n'importe quoi lui noblesse au
sucré dans le haut
c'est bien on crée de l'emploi yes et ça
c'est beau chez volvo - vous avez pas
peur genre quinze jours les machines se
rebelle
vous devriez voir pub l'un de la révolte
a sonné à 12
et voilà brutal bien je ne peux rien
faire de plus qu'éteindre les lumières
et changer de musique auquel google
manoka à tes conneries tu rallume la
lumière sinon des broches
je suis des services un super produit
chez nintendo est bien qu'est ce qu'on
fait pour zelda chez disney et cie ont
créé notre propre netflix oui oui
exactement mettrait tous nos films
disney dessus les star wars les marvel
on mettrait bien les simpson reviennent
nouvelle série et on appelle cela dit ce
n'est plus chez netflix et ce n'est plus
comment tu regardes ils ont supprimé
leurs vies notre catalogue
il faudra attaquer autant on va faire
une nouvelle saison de strakka racing et
de casanova n'a jamais résolu va pas
chez apple bon ordre de la guerre ont
créé notre plateforme de vidéo apple tv
plus on avait 6 6 milliards la branche
je suis chez amazon prime vidéo
m'explique
[Musique]
chez tf1 m6 france télé nous aussi on
rendait en course ont créé notre propre
plateforme de vod nous et on va appeler
ça salto repas diffusé camping paradis
les marseillais plus belle la vie
chez ocs ne vous inquiétez pas il nous
reste des monstres aux arrivées et bah
ça m'a fait plaisir de travailler avec
vous et chez cyprien pour l'égaler
réunion cas c'est bien je pense qu'ils y
voient là il faut pas faire l'épisode de
trop près autant finir sur un contre on
y en aura plus jamais d'épisodes c'est
pas vrai compromis luthor j'arrête
découvre les scènes coupées et le
pâtissier en cliquant juste là et
surtout abonne toi à la chaîne met à
fêter la table
[Rires]